why were most of you
in the mob
democrats when you were in the life
but republican or you know independent
center right you know whatever you want
to call it once you guys left the life
that's kind of interesting to me i keep
talking to guys where
you know even
leonetti you know even uh sammy some of
these willianetti is still on the uh
democrat but why were some of these guys
democrats when you were in the life what
happened what changed well i think with
trump because trump is a new yorker and
he's got that way about him yeah we're
attracted to him for me it's about his
policies but i won't get into that but
on the street
we hated the republicans because they
were the law and order uh party got it
the democrats were easier to corrupt
every politician that we knew that we
corrupted they were all democrats every
single one unpacked though what do you
mean by that
you know guys that we had on the payroll
guys that would do us favors guys that
got me licenses for my gasps they were
all democrats so if you if you went up
to a republican saying listen i need a
gas license what would they say to you
or did you not even we didn't do it we
didn't approach it because you knew
there's 20 democrats around to do it so
you had in the 80s what is this yeah 80s
70s 80s yeah all the way through but
dude the the start of the democratic
party with tammany hall and with boss
tweet i mean the the big
the big tent idea is you know vote early
vote often chicago politics i mean it's
it's pretty well documented man you your
folks are uh not exactly the most noble
creatures walking the place of the earth
it's it's like my dad hated ronald
reagan don't let him bully you brother
ronald reagan's a rat yeah he's a ratty
you know he goes he doesn't like
italians he goes after all the mob guys
well that that's his job you know you
know you're supposed to come back oh
your dad said that to you about race so
your dad was a democrat democrat all the
way interesting and like i said the guys
that we were closest to they were all
democrats so democrats were more
friendlier with the mob and they were
okay with looking away and letting you
do your thing so yes a hoover uh kennedy
these
these guys were like listen you guys do
as long as you do your thing and you do
us favors we're gonna leave you guys
alone joe kennedy was uh was a
bootlegger you know that he was involved
in prohibition yeah it was close with
costello and a couple of guys that knew
him well that's how this whole deal came
together with the kennedys you know i
meet esposito i mean it's it's public
knowledge now he was very close to a
good friend of mine richard givenelli
and another guy i don't want to mention
to me still around and uh you know
fritzy was with uh chin giganti mead did
us a lot of favors yeah mario biaggi the
same thing these guys passed on now
cuomo how much is sorry how much of this
is because for a long time the unions
did represent the working man and you
guys were the working man in the
democratic party wanted to represent the
working man and this was part of the
fabric of everyday life so you know it's
one thing that they were corruptible but
i'm sure you know just to play devil's
advocate and and to unbreak adam's heart
it's like i'm sure like in some way
there was a wink of a nod like how much
more money do these rich republicans
need how much more money do these robber
baron nixon republicans need man so i
mean it's like what am i going to come
down on the guy that what's he doing
running numbers come on you know so i
mean how much of it was like that and
don't get me wrong it wasn't that we
were selective we had to go with a
democrat we didn't care if you're
democratic republican independent or
whatever it just so happens that the
guys that were easiest to get to were
democrats you're saying that you don't
care about the red or the blue you care
about the green oh exactly exactly we
didn't care who it was right
i'm interested in the in the structure
you talked about before because you know
you're talking about
the the way that you guys were able to
build out the way that you were able to
build out infiltrate all parts of life
you guys had this corporate structure
the commission was one of the first true
c-suite boards in america
but you guys don't have i'm assuming you
don't have user manuals and there's no
orientation you know it's not you're not
going away on a weekend
manual the eventual was a user manual
and that's what they used to come after
them
was the user manual so he gave that up
to everybody so for years before that
how how was the structure passed on it
was just word of mouth or i can't
imagine there was a mafia oriented
congratulations on being a maid man come
this way and we'll teach you day one on
what's code red in the marines
i only know because of one of my
favorite movies of all time and i'm
assuming it's a sick movie right code
red was a real thing for a long time but
was it really of course it was wow but
it's not something that you talk about
right there's a lot of things uh you
know i don't know who i was talking to
michael that said
you know the best guy he dealt with i
don't know if it was sugar man i don't
know who it was and one of these guys i
spoke to
he said uh the best gangsters were the
ones like meyer lansky never wrote
anything down on paper
he was a even harvey keitel when they
were the movie he talks about it in
there says never write anything down on
paper everything was here exactly the
guys that did it right they tracked like
if they knew this guy owed him 10 grand
or 20 grand
it wasn't written anywhere like an excel
spreadsheet hey uh you know mr director
of uh it was like hey uh you know what
you did last month where's that ten
thousand dollars what do you mean ten
thousand dollars well you know i know
what you did
so it was a lot of memorization the guys
that did it right
so so you you almost had to have a
certain skill that's not a duplicatable
exactly
i want to tell you this and this is the
god's honest truth i never wrote
anything down before i went to prison i
would never forget a phone number i
would never forget who owed me money i
never forget a name never at that level
that much money never never never forget
anything
when i went to prison and this is the
truth so many guys would hit me up with
deals and stories and this that i would
yeah yeah i would let it go one in one
ear one out the other one i came out of
prison i couldn't remember a name or
phone number or anything else
and it stuck and you were locked in you
were in the zone locked in but back back
in the day well you know what you know
what my father
by the way my father used to tell me the
the telephone is a cop
that's how you look at the phone
when we were in my house in rosalind
long island yeah my dad wanted to talk
to me when he was on parole he's come on
let's go we need to take a walk and he
would talk to me like this like a
pitcher on the mound
talk to me like that or we would go into
the bathroom he would turn on the
faucets we would lean our heads into the
faucet and he'd be standing there
flushing the toilet to make sure that
nobody can hear him
he ingrained that in me
i never got caught on a wiretap i never
had any of that stuff that i had to
worry about because i looked i was not i
don't want to use the word paranoid it
was extremely careful has any of that
stuck around till today or no like you
know how sometimes you know like i was
born in iran so if i hear a certain
alarm like it takes me straight back to
iran if i hear a certain noise is it
still in there or same way and
truthfully
i hate talking on a phone i i still
don't like it i just i'm not comfortable
with it if you live that life there's
someone that's just on your cell phone
you don't yeah i don't like to talk on
the phone you see my very few phone
calls your dad is saying the phone's a
cop and everybody is like hi cop what is
the name of they're using syria
but you made a comment about mario cuomo
kai do you have that video about mario
como what you guys talked about as well
as what giuliani said about mario como
if you have that i i wouldn't mind
because when we were sitting down go
ahead no it's a great great baseball
player as well mario cuomo for people
that no no he's a big yankee prospect
they got one of the biggest signing
bonuses of all time at one point but by
the way he was a guy that was loved and
admired by a lot of people a lot of
people from both sides based on what you
read about the guy respect it so i asked
you guys about mario como comments came
up it was not necessarily intentional
just kind of came up and uh you guys
both said maybe if you want to share you
guys both talked about how mario's
involvement it was you know yes
and the mob it was
he he was friendly with guys on the
street yeah so so here's what rudy said
about mario cuomo kai if you want to
play it it's uh
uh by the way uh
yeah and with rudy we sat down for three
and a half hours at his place if he
could have he would have kept you there
all day
oh and if we release what what giuliani
said oh i don't you know like some of
the stuff that julia maybe that may be
episode eight nine ten that people have
to watch it but some of the stuff that
he says it's gonna be yeah uh uh uh it's
not gonna be good for some folks out
there so but go ahead play play what
giuliani said about it
the uh
many names were brought up so i asked
him i said who was easier to
bribe you know when you were a mobster
was it the republicans the democrats who
was it they said not even close it was
always easier to bribe and buy
you know democrats i said give me names
who anybody that maybe you work with
they can talk about we started kind of
going through a list of names they spoke
very favorably about mario cuomo
governor mario comey yeah i would too
yeah and they they said very good things
but they also said we had them in our
pockets and you know meaning you know
so you you adam they had they had they
had him in their pocket
somewhat because of his own
of his own limitations in his thinking
and somewhat because of his wife
so his wife's family
and i hate to say this because she's a
lovely woman i think matilda is
just a grand lady
but this is part of the italian
experience
had mafia connections
and the governor was always afraid that
if he ran they would be exploited
and i owe and i i opposed mario in the
sense of my political philosophy was
really different than his certainly at
that point in my life
even though i endorsed him for governor
well i'll explain why later i needed the
money
for the city
i don't think
i know i know and really can't quite
describe in detail to you wouldn't be
right the details of it and it's not
nearly as serious as
he thought it was
i mean it's the kind of thing you could
easily explain as had nothing to do with
matilda
had nothing to do with mario
and it's the kind of thing that happened
back in those days when
you had to conduct a business and if you
didn't play ball with them
you were gonna
they were victims they weren't
they easily could have been interpreted
that way that's the way i interpreted it
uh but he he
he saw shadows about it you know how
sometimes people
are more embarrassed about something
than they should be i always thought
that was the case with mario largely
because he was very ethical and a very
good man mario was yeah very very good
man and uh someone i respected great
even though
even though i thought some of his
political ideas were outdated that whole
thing about
you know there's two americas one for
the rich one for the poor i think well i
think that ended during the depression
and
uh
i didn't think if he ran he would get
elected
i thought he could be nominated but i
thought his message was too
outdated and i don't think
thoughts
i agree with him yeah i i definitely
agree with him i mean he was uh
he was a friend to us
i put it that way
unlike his son
sons
oh andrew well he's he's it's good to
know though that he actually isn't uh
you know abuse of her hands he's just
italian so there's that
who now andrew cuomo that's what he said
he didn't he didn't know he didn't abuse
any of those women he's just italian
we're here you know what his downfall
really was he's a bully
and he turned everybody against him
andrew yeah andrew andrew he's just he's
an abusive type of guy
he wasn't well liked he had some loyalty
that he bought you know just people
around him but
at the end of the day when you're a
bully and you mistreat people like that
the tide is going to turn yeah now some
may say michael trump is a bully
okay you know would you would you say
because the the argument could go from
the other side well trump bullied a lot
of guys as well to on his way up but you
know what the people around trump really
like him
interesting the paul manafort yeah the
the corey lewandowski's people that were
close to him they like him look you say
what you want about trump
i believe trump really cared about
america
he cared about it and whether it was his
ego whatever it is that he wanted to be
the best possible guy he can be in there
for the country i think that's what he
wanted to be whatever motivated him i
don't know but i feel he he really it
really meant something for him to do
well for the country for america that he
believed in and i that's why i supported
him would you have been able would you
have been able to accomplish what you
accomplished in in the gas cam without
mario cuomo's help
yes because my
the licenses i obtained were not through
cuomo okay with somebody else
but uh i needed those licenses and they
were tough to get and he was able to i
was able to get him and that's what
that's what kind of separated me from a
lot of the guys because i had 18
licenses
so you you couldn't
unless you indicted me and put me in
jail you couldn't stop my business
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]